back in brussels for another go at
striking a trade deal with his european
union counterparts
we're going to be working very hard to
try and get a deal we're going to see
what happens in negotiations today
and we will be looking forward to
meeting our european colleagues later on
this afternoon thank you very much
the resumed talks between david frost
and the eu's michelle barnier came after
an
hour-long phone call between ursula van
der lion president of the european
commission
and british prime minister boris johnson
their joint statement
on saturday mentioned progress over the
last week but said the two sides still
didn't see eye to eye on three critical
issues
firstly there's fishing rights in other
words what access eu fishing fleets have
to uk waters
and how quickly any changes happen then
there's a more fundamental question of
the level playing field
that's measures to ensure businesses on
one side don't have an unfair advantage
brussels wants the uk to stick closely
to its rules
on things like workers rights
environmental regulations and especially
state aid to businesses lastly there's
governance including how any agreement
would be enforced
and what role institutions such as the
european court of justice would have
if no deals in place by the end of the
year the uk will be operating under
world trade organization rules with a
block that accounted for 43 percent of
british exports
and 51 of uk imports last year
the british government says it's ready
for such a scenario but business groups
are warning of major disruption
there'll be no formal cooperation
between the two sides
so all kinds of goods can get held up at
the border
a lot of businesses who do trade with
europe will go under
our manufacturing industries are very
exposed farming's very exposed even
fishing
is incredibly exposed even if there is a
deal customs checks and paperwork could
create a real challenge
we know that there won't be tariffs and
quotas under a deal i mean that's
obvious it would be ridiculous
to impose stars and quotas but we do not
know to what extent that the eu
will allow manufacturing parts
cars chemicals
parts of the aerospace industry
to to flow freely into the eu markets
and the talks could get overtaken by
events in the westminster parliament
for monday it's set to re-examine the
internal market bill
which breaks the terms of the uk's
already agreed protocol on northern
ireland
that could kill off any prospect of
giving negotiations yet another final
chance
nadim baba al jazeera